من السادس عشر من فبراير وحتى 28 من
فبراير يعود مهرجان فنون العلا في نسخته
الثانيه للاحتفال بالاعمال الابداعيه على
انواعها من روائع الفن المعاصر الى
التراكيب الفنيه العملاقه في وسط الصحراء
الشهره انجي واهل في العلا وهو اهم
فعاليات نسخه العام يتضمن اكبر مجموعه من
اعمال الفنان العالمي انت ورهر تعرض لاول
مره في منطقه الشرق الاوسط في قاعه مرايا
المذهله منطقه الجديده قلب الغلا تحولت
قريبا الى وجهه للمشاه فقط واصبحت احدث
وجهه حيويه في العلاقه هي موطن لاول سينما
في الهواء الطلق تحتضن النشاطات والعروض
المختلفه بالاضافه الى لوحات المرسومه
يدويا وتزين رايك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى العلا من جديد تنضم الينا مره اخيره
زميلتنا نادين خماج نادين ختامها مسك نختم
بمعرض فنون العلا تفضلي نادين
وسهام يعني احنا بنختم صباح العربيه مثل
ما بداناه اليوم من العلم من البلده
القديمه بالتحديد وانا بعرف انه انت بتحبي
البخور بدي اقول لك انه نحن وين موجودين
في هاي البلد القديمه وهذا الشارع بالذات
هو امتداد لطريق البخور قديما يعني في كذا
موقع ينطلق من كذا موقع فنحن الان في
امتداد طريق البخور قديما يعني نحن بين
الماضي والحاضر مجلس اليوم على كل حال مثل
ما بدات كلامك بالحديث عن فنون العلى
اليوم نتحدث عن مدرسه الديره هي اول مركز
مخصصه للفنون وايضا التصاميم في العلاقه
على كل حال هو معلم من معالم جديده هذا
الحي الجديد
الذي يقع بها القرب من البلده القديمه في
العلا ويمكن ان نتحدث عن منطقه ثقافي وفني
واجتماعي حيوي في البلده القديمه في
العراق على كل حال نرحب بضيفتنا نور الدبل
المديره تنفيذ الفنون والصناعات الابداعيه
يسعد هالصباح نوره اهلا وسهلا صباح الخير
نادين صباح النور
نوره عندما نقول مدرسه الديره يعني ما هي
السوره التي تنطبع في ازهارها ما طبيعه
هذه المدرسه ما الفعاليات التي تقدمها
اولا
المدرسه
لتكون مركز لتطوير الحرف وتدريب بالحرفيين
على بعض همم الحرف وتقديم برامج ل همم
العامه همم بعد هذه الفتره بدا او همم
الطلاب باستخدام هذه الحرف لتطوير جداريات
لتطوير اعمال فنيه بنشوفها في في الجديده
اليوم هل نتحدث عن فعاليات معينه ضمن
مهرجان الفنون العلا في مدرسه الديره
بالتحديد برامج فنون برامج فنون العلا تم
توظيفها لي
مهرجان
الفن بعض الحرفيات عندهم
بداوا بانتاج بعض اعمالهم من ضمنها انه
مجوهرات هناك ايضا ورش عمل همم
لطلاب المدارس
وكذلك للزوار همم من ضمنها السلك سكرين
اللي هي مستوحه من همم معرض همم شهره
والذي سيكون افتتاح ان شاء الله في مهرجان
الفنا
طيب نوره يعني حي الجديد هو قريب ملاصق
تقريبا للبلده القديمه وفيه يعني بيوت
جديده اليوم واماكن جديده طب اليوم كيف
يمكن توظيف فنون العلا من خلال مهرجان
العلا وايضا الفنون المدعومه بشكل عام
لجعل حي الجديده مقصد سياحي وجاب لي
الصيام
اعاده توظيف الاماكن الموجوده في الجديده
لتكون ملتقى للمبدعين والفنانين من ضمنها
همم مركز همم برامج الاقامه الفنيه من
ضمنها استديو للموسيقى همم
بدانا الحين نشوف كثير من همم المبدعين
يبداوا يشتغلوا في الجديده بيعرضوا
اعمالهم
طيب نورا اليوم اذا نحن بدنا نستفيد من
مكونات حي الجديده وايضا المكان الجغرافي
لحيل جديده وملاصق لهذه البلده القديمه
والبلده الاثريه والتاريخيه كيف يمكن ان
نستفيد من موقعه موقع المدرسه فيه لكن دون
تغيير وضع لحالي وتحويل الى حي للفنون
البصريه
همم بالنسبه
للمنطقه زي ما ذكرتي نادين في البدايه همم
طريق البخور هو كان همم
مكان لالتقاء همم
الزوار او همم
للمنطقه من جميع
المناطق وتبادل همم تبادل همم
المنتجات همم
اللي حاصل اليوم هو بالضبط همم اعاده همم
احياء لهذه المنطقه تبقى ملتقى للحضارات
يجتمعوا فيها وهمم الاحتفاء بجميع انواع
الفنون من ضمنها الان انواع البصريات
طيب نورا في اقبال كبير على المدرسه
وبصراحه من مين اكثر من الجنسين نساء من
الرجال طبعا
المدرسه يمكن لو اذكر شوي عنا بداياتها هي
اول مدرسه همم للبنات في العلافه همم
وكانت مدرسه لفتره طويله من الابتدائي الى
الثانويه على مختلف المراحل
المدرسه مفتوحه للجميع فيها همم
ورش عمل تستقبل الجميع من ضمنها ورش عمل
السيراميك همم الحرف
همم
المجوهرات
همم تاصيل
اساسيات التصميم همم فمفتوحه للجميع همم
النساء والرجال
طيب الدوره لماذا تم اختيار هذا المكان
بالتحديد يعني نعرف بان مدرسه الديره كانت
مدرسه للبنات سابقا
مدرسه الديره يمكن ااا لما ااا
تكلمنا مع الناس وبدانا نشوف تاريخها اييي
كان فيها ثلاث فصول للفن اا وبالنسبه
لمدرسه حكوميه في وقتها كانت بتحتفي
بالفنون بجميع انواعها كانوا كانوا الطلاب
بيحبوا يروحوا هناك ليه همم
لممارسه الفن بشكل عام فاا حبينا ان همم
نبقى هذا همم الاثر والتواصل مع همم مع
همم الطالبات وكمان اتاحتها لشريحه اكبر
للمجتمع
على كل حال احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر نوره
دبل مدير التنفيذي للفنون والصناعات
الابداعيه كنتي معانا في هذا الاستديو
الخارجي من البلده القديمه في العلا شكرا
نوره